Yes, we would trust the results more because we're holding one of these factors
constant. When more factors are held constant, the test is more reliable because
these conditions are the same for all people that took the test. We always have
to think about extraneous factors, things that can impact the outcome that we
may not have thought about. These extraneous factors can impact the outcome, in
this case, our memory. These extraneous factors are often called lurking
variables. They just lurk around waiting to ambush your results. It's really
difficult to account for every possible extraneous factor. But this is something
to be aware of, not only as you're going through this course, but when you
analyze data in your daily lives.